ils sont hôtelier gérant de golf ou
encore restaurateurs et participe à la
première réunion de la cci versailles
yvelines
autour de la filière golfique en ligne
de mire la ryder cup de saint quentin en
yvelines
il faut plus voir la ryder cup comme
étant une extraordinaire opportunité
pour valoriser le golf dans les yvelines
pourquoi parce que la ryder cup en fait
c'est le troisième événement sportif le
plus médiatisé au monde que le golf en
france le golf français n'est pas très
connu
dans le monde tout simplement la france
n'est pas une destination golfique pour
les clientèles étrangères et que
justement la ryder cup va pouvoir mettre
en avant ces deux filières environ 70000
visiteurs seront attendus par jour sur
le golf de saint quentin en yvelines
imaginez des package faire remonter des
besoins plus d'une centaine de
professionnels ont échangé durant cette
matinée des package avec une synergie
hôtelière qui me paraissent extrêmement
important ainsi qu'une remise en
question des services qu'on apporte à
nos propres clients voire surtout les
clients étrangers
ils se remettent en question est ce
qu'on est à la hauteur de leurs de leur
vision du gold ce qu'ils furent cherche
et bien sûr pas développer de nouveaux
services d'autres réunions sont prévues
durant l'année le premier coup de potter
de la ryder cup sera donné le 28
septembre 2018
[Applaudissements]